ce qui manquait jusqu'à février 2022
c'est l'exposition d'une vision claire
de ce qu'on voulait faire en termes de
politique énergétique et c'est une
histoire qui court sur une décennie
celle d'une valse hésitation sur
l'avenir du nucléaire français de
François Hollande à Emmanuel Macron de
2012 à 2022 premier acte la période
socialiste au cœur des auditions de la
commission d'enquête figure une loi de
2015 c'est elle qui a prévu la
diminution de la part du nucléaire en
France de 75 à 50%. cet objectif je le
reçois je suis censé le mettre en
application une loi qui résulte en effet
d'un accord entre le Parti socialiste et
les Verts avant la présidentielle de
2012 un accord aujourd'hui remise en
cause par certains pour moi c'est un
accord de cuantables c'est-à-dire qu'on
s'est mis d'accord sur un marqueur
politique et on s'est retrouvé avec un
programme qui expliquait qu'il fallait
fermer 24 réacteurs les 50% elle était
le résultat d'aucune étude d'impact
ou analyse de besoins une absence
d'analyse de fond qui va conduire à
beaucoup d'atermoiements les ministres
de l'écologie qui vont se succéder vont
se retrouver prises en étau entre une
promesse politique et l'impossibilité
pratique de la mettre en œuvre pour
savoir si on est capable de maintenir ou
de baisser à 50 % la part du nucléaire
il faut d'abord être sûr d'avoir réussi
en matière d'économie d'énergie et
d'énergie renouvelable et au moment où
je suis voté la loi je ne sais pas si on
va réussir résultat pour résoudre le
problème on le dissout la loi de 2015
affiche l'objectif de 50% nucléaires à
horizon 2025 mais sans préciser par
quels moyens vient alors l'acte 2 le
premier quinquennat d'Emmanuel Macron le
nouveau président ne remet pas en cause
l'objectif fixé par son prédécesseur en
2018 il annonce la fermeture de 14
réacteurs l'horizon en est repoussé à
2035 mission toujours impossible rien
n'avait été prévu pardon de le dire
d'abord combien de temps pour démanteler
combien d'emplois est-ce qu'il y a des
reconversions possibles tout cela
n'avait pas été fait finalement seul
Fessenheim sera fermé avant que le
président ne perd une volte face
Emmanuel Macron en 2022 décide de
relancer un vaste programme nucléaire un
changement de pied que le gouvernement
doit aujourd'hui expliquer on ne
raisonne plus de la même façon puisqu'on
a maintenant une vision beaucoup plus
ambitieuse sur la réduction de nos
émissions de gaz à effet de serre et
donc sur les besoins de production
en électricité